griffin jacks
he's taking his bumps a little bit
lately but hopefully he's able to make
an adjustment and learn and he's
pitching in uncharted territory pitching
deep into september for the first time
and see if he's able to find his legs
and find a second win for this last part
of the season and finish with a few good
starts
nikki lopez
had eight hits
a home run and four rbis against the
orioles
grounded left side and up the line
his bat has become like a magic wand
it doesn't matter
oh he'll take his 17th double two on one
out
then he had a good series in baltimore
six for 15 including a home run
the 1-1 pitch is swung on and hit high
in the air deep to right that's a way
back and it is out of here
home run andrew benintendi and the
royals take a three-nothing lead
and andrew who's just been on everything
lately that was another high arcing shot
much like the one we saw at camden yards
where it went all the way to utah street
we all know
big surprises come in small packages
and he was right on that perfect timing
look at the straight front leg
just
just great balance there and he
generated some power from his legs there
and here's the lineup tonight against
daniel lynch
will be facing minnesota for the first
time in his career
and that's not good for minnesota byron
buxton is back from the injured list
lynch kicks a 2-0 to the plate and byron
hits this ball deep to center field this
ball is gone
way into the night
[Applause]
3-1 in favor of kansas city as byron
buxton obliterates a 2-0 pitch
into the sweets in straight away center
field his 12th of the year
that snaps an old for 11 for byron and
the twins are on the board
here's donaldson with men on the corners
and nobody out
swung on and hit deep to left for
donaldson
gone
[Applause]
a three-run rocket to left in the twin
slingshot into the lead
it's 4-3 minnesota with nobody out in
the home first nice job by donaldson of
keeping this ball fair you see it pull
the hands in
release the top hand off the bat trying
to create a little room for that ball so
it didn't jam him and
well had a little hook to it but it's
amazing
that ball stayed fair
jeffers off the end of the bat squirts
one into center field and a nice play
by merrifield in short center field
makes the catch one pitch one away
and trying to get something to hit this
here
said it was a slider
you know polacco went up there
took an aggressive swing hit the ball
hard against the guy
and that's to right field kepler thought
about
making a move for it but it's going to
drop for a lead off single
so he has two hits tonight
the batter will be michael a taylor
and taylor got a slider up and he gets
it by simmons
that'll get ben and tendy to third
taylor is digging for second and now ben
attendee comes around third base and
simmons couldn't unload the throw
so a line drive by the shortstop results
and andrew benintendi scoring from first
and the royals have tied the game in the
fourth 108 past
the gold glover couldn't even touch it
that ball was hit hard it was perfect
because
buxton was playing on the opposite side
of the second base
and then ben and tindy had did such a
good job of cutting the corner and
rounding third and vance wilson said i'm
gonna send him
and it was a great decision
they're at the corners for buxton who
has already tonight he had a bomb 457
feet above the batter's eye
and he made a good pitch rivero was set
up inside and he got it just off the
plate
so it only cost lynch one more pitch
is scoreless in the fourth
grounder to second they're going to come
home and
there's the tag nice job by jeffers
keeping the ball in the glove before i
was anticipating a collision at home
plate right there
polanco
good
job of getting this ball to jeffers
quickly and as you said
fortunate that ball stayed in his glove
[Music]
there's a line drive and a catch by
monday at third
so brent rooker is out number two
talked about his elite speed
oh he has elite quickness to first step
second step that's what got that
snagged it
stolen base hit from it
dribbled up the line gonna be a tough
play
and alcala tags the runner
who had to avoid the fielder
and if lopez didn't
pull anything trying to evade the
pitcher and then getting back on the
baseline
he's in pretty good shape that was an
awkward play
but the twins got the out not all
pitchers could make this play but does a
nice job of understanding who's running
beat him to the ball
a strikeout a quick one at that of
santana three pitches and there's one
out
foul tip jeffers hangs on strikeout
number two for coleman since the first
pitch single by ben and tendy
has done what he has done so regularly
in the second half of the year
high fly left field
ref schneider comes in
another scoreless inning for alexander
coleman we'll see if the twins can walk
it off in the night
base is loaded
and two down
grounded
polanco fires across the snow what a
play by the twin second baseman
throwing on the run sidearming it on
target to suno and the royals leave the
bases full
anybody with a bat in their hand can
hurt you execute ooh man there's a line
drive and it's going to be caught by
nikki lopez
[Applause]
he's left it right there for him to hit
game ending line drive base hit until
nikki lopez took three or four steps
reached up and put it right in his
webbing
yeah
beautiful now
right man at the whole plate now
and ben and tandy swings drives it to
left that's deep that's a way back it's
gone
home run andrew benintendi what a night
he's had and the royals lead it six to
four
and he got him looking to end the game
and what a game it was
[Music]